Wir glauben, dass Quantencomputer es uns ermöglichen werden, bestimmte Probleme schneller zu lösen, als wir es mit klassischen Computern allein könnten. Aber
zu verstehen, wie das funktioniert, ist nicht so einfach. Heute werden wir in Qiskit in the Classroom versuchen, die Quelle der Kraft von
Quantencomputing zu ergründen, indem wir uns einen der allerersten
Algorithmen anschauen. Willkommen bei Qiskit in the Classroom. In dieser Reihe nutzen wir Qiskit, um einige grundlegende
Konzepte zu erkunden, die häufig in Kursen rund um Quantencomputing behandelt werden. Jedes Video wird von einem interaktiven Modul begleitet,
das in der Beschreibung unten verlinkt ist. Schau also dort unbedingt nach. Wenn du viel über Quantencomputer gehört hast, hast du
wahrscheinlich gehört, dass sie Quantenphänomene wie Superposition, Verschränkung und Interferenz nutzen können, um
Probleme auf eine Weise zu lösen, die klassische Computer nicht können. Aber wie genau helfen diese Eigenschaften? Im Jahr 1985 war David Deutsch der
Erste, der zeigte, wie das möglich sein könnte. Er entwickelte das, was heute als Deutschs Algorithmus bekannt ist und ein
Problem effizienter lösen konnte als ein klassischer Algorithmus. Heute schauen wir uns Deutschs Algorithmus und
eine spätere Erweiterung namens Deutsch-Jozsa-Algorithmus an und untersuchen, wie die einzigartigen Quanteneigenschaften der qubits
zum Vorteil des Quantencomputers genutzt werden können. Dann lassen wir diese Algorithmen mit Qiskit auf einem echten Quantencomputer laufen.
Es gibt noch andere Quantenalgorithmen, die ebenfalls einen theoretischen Vorteil gegenüber bekannten klassischen Algorithmen zeigen. Und nicht alle funktionieren
nach denselben Prinzipien wie die, die wir heute sehen werden. Was wir heute lernen, erklärt also nicht allgemein, wie ein Quantencomputer
funktioniert, aber es hilft uns, zu verstehen, wie die Prinzipien der Quantenmechanik kombiniert werden können, um
einen leistungsfähigen Quantencomputer zu bauen. Bevor wir in Deutschs Algorithmus einsteigen, lass uns zunächst darüber nachdenken, wie Quantencomputer
sich von klassischen Computern unterscheiden und wie uns das einen Vorteil beim Lösen bestimmter
Probleme verschaffen könnte. Ein Unterschied ist, dass die Quantenbits, sogenannte qubits, sich in Superpositionszuständen befinden können. Anstatt auf
den Nullzustand oder den Einszustand beschränkt zu sein, wie es bei einem klassischen Bit der Fall ist, kann ein qubit
in einem Superpositionszustand aus sowohl null als auch eins sein. Wir schreiben diesen Zustand so:
wobei a und b komplexe Zahlen sind, deren Quadrate sich zu eins aufaddieren, und je mehr
qubits, desto weiter dehnt sich diese Lücke aus. Zwei klassische Bits können immer noch nur in einem dieser
vier möglichen Zustände sein: 0 0, 0 1, 1 0 oder 1
1. Zwei qubits können sich in einer Superposition aller vier dieser klassisch erlaubten Zustände befinden, was
so geschrieben wird. Im Allgemeinen kann ein klassisches System aus n Bits immer nur in genau einem von 2 hoch n möglichen
Kombinationen aus Nullen und Einsen sein. Ein Quantensystem aus n qubits kann in einer Superposition aller 2 hoch n dieser
Zustände sein. Die Skalierung ist exponentiell. Selbst wenn wir nur 10 qubits hätten,
könnten diese in einem Superpositionszustand von 2 hoch 10 sein, also 1.024 mögliche Kombinationen aus Nullen und
Einsen. Die exponentielle Skalierung des Zustandsraums von qubits wird als Quanten-
parallelismus bezeichnet und ist teilweise für den Vorteil von Quantencomputern gegenüber klassischen Computern verantwortlich. Aber ein Quantencomputer
ist nicht nur ein massiver Parallelprozessor. Nur weil die qubits in einem Quantencomputer in einer
Superposition von exponentiell vielen Zuständen sein können, bedeutet das nicht, dass wir Zugriff auf alle Informationen in jedem dieser
Zustände haben. Da die Messung das System in einen bestimmten Zustand kollabiert, wollen wir uns
ansehen, wie sich das bei einem einfachen Problem verhält. Stell dir eine Maschine vor,
der du ein einzelnes Bit zuführst. Sie wendet dann eine Funktion auf das Bit an und gibt ein weiteres einzelnes Bit aus. Die Maschine
befindet sich in einer Black Box, auf die wir keinen Zugriff haben. Worauf wir Zugriff haben, ist das Bit,
das wir ihr zuführen – x – und das Bit, das die Box ausgibt – f
von x. Wir wollen herausfinden, was die Funktion f ist, die die Maschine anwendet.
Es gibt vier mögliche Funktionen, die ein einzelnes Bit auf ein anderes einzelnes Bit abbilden.
Um also herauszufinden, was die Funktion ist, können wir ihr einfach eine Null zuführen und schauen, ob sie eine Null oder eine Eins ausgibt, dann ihr
eine Eins zuführen und dasselbe tun. Jeder dieser beiden Schritte wird als Abfrage bezeichnet. Das
ist eine Möglichkeit, klassische und Quantenalgorithmen zu vergleichen – durch das sogenannte Abfragemodell, bei dem wir die Anzahl
der Abfragen vergleichen, die jeder der Algorithmen an die Black Box stellen muss, um das Problem zu lösen. In diesem Fall hat unsere
klassische Methode die Box zweimal abfragen müssen, um die Funktion zu erfahren. Mal sehen, ob wir es besser machen können, wenn wir einen Quantencomputer
die Black Box abfragen lassen. Anstatt zuerst eine Null und dann eine Eins zuzuführen,
kann der Quantencomputer der Box ein qubit zuführen, das sich in einer Superposition aus null und
eins befindet. Damit führen wir der Box mit einer einzigen Abfrage effektiv beide Eingaben zu. Aber
bedeutet das, dass wir die Funktion mit nur einer Abfrage erfahren können?
Leider ist das nicht der Fall. Warum diese Idee scheitert, sehen wir, wenn wir sie auf einem Quantencomputer testen. Wir erstellen einen
circuit mit zwei qubits. qubit null, hier durch diese obere Linie dargestellt, ist unser Eingangszustand X, den wir der
Black Box zuführen, die hier durch das kastanienbraune gate mit der Bezeichnung UF dargestellt wird. Das UF gate
ist so konzipiert, dass es ein qubit null als Eingangszustand X nimmt und dann eine Transformation auf qubit eins anwendet, die
den Zustand null in den Zustand f von x. Solange qubit 1 im Zustand
null gestartet ist, ist die Ausgabe x auf qubit 0 und f von x auf qubit 1. Um also f von x für
sowohl x=0 als auch x=1 gleichzeitig zu finden, können wir versuchen, qubit 0 in eine Superposition aus 0 und 1 zu versetzen, bevor
wir es in die Black Box einspeisen. Das geschieht mit diesem roten Hadamard gate, das den Nullzustand in 1 / 2
0 + 1 transformiert. Nach dem Black-Box-gate sollten wir nun eine Superposition aus beiden
f von 0 und f von 1 auf qubit 1 haben. Wenn wir die beiden qubits messen, hoffen wir,
die Frage zu beantworten: Welche Funktion steckt in der Black Box? Nutzen wir den Qiskit Primitive Sampler, um das
circuit auszuführen und das Ergebnis zurückzugeben. Wir können die Anzahl der Ausführungen des circuit, genannt Samples, durch Ändern dieses
Parameters namens Shots hier festlegen.
Das entspricht der Anzahl der Anfragen, die wir an die Black Box stellen. Schauen wir mal, ob eine einzige Anfrage
funktioniert. Hier ist das Ergebnis. Wir haben gemessen, dass qubit 0 null ist. Das war also
der Eingabewert x und qubit 1 ist 1, was der Ausgabewert f von x war. Jetzt
wissen wir, dass f von 0 gleich 1 ist. Aber was ist mit f von 1? Hier liegt das Problem. Sobald
wir den Zustand gemessen haben, kollabiert die Superposition und wir konnten nur einen Teil der Funktion mit einer
einzelnen Anfrage messen. Das sagt uns nicht alles, was wir wissen müssen, um zu bestimmen, welche Funktion es ist. Wir würden eine
zweite Anfrage an die Box benötigen. Auch wenn das Prinzip des Quanten-Parallelismus es uns erlaubt, gleichzeitig
die Black Box f von 0 und f von 1 auswerten zu lassen, haben wir keinen Zugriff auf beide
dieser Antworten. Quanten-Parallelismus allein reicht nicht aus. Deutschs Algorithmus
zeigt, wie wir Quanten-Parallelismus etwas anders nutzen können, um etwas über die Funktion in der Black Box zu erfahren. Wir werden
nicht genau erfahren, was die Funktion ist, aber wir werden mit einer
einzelnen Anfrage etwas Neues darüber herausfinden, was mit einem klassischen Computer nicht möglich wäre. Schauen wir uns zunächst eine Tabelle der vier möglichen
Funktionen an, die ein einzelnes Bit auf ein anderes einzelnes Bit abbilden. Hier siehst du, dass zwei der Funktionen f_sub_1 und f_sub_4 immer
einen einzigen Wert zurückgeben, unabhängig vom Eingabezustand. Wir nennen diese beiden Funktionen
konstant. f_sub_2 und f_sub_3 geben je nach
Zustand von x entweder null oder eins zurück. Wir nennen diese beiden Funktionen balanciert. Deutschs Algorithmus
bestimmt, ob die Funktion konstant oder balanciert ist, indem er einige clevere Anpassungen am circuit vornimmt, den wir
zuvor verwendet haben. Hier ist der circuit. Er beginnt damit, qubit 0 in den Zustand 1 /
2 0 + 1 zu versetzen, mit einem Hadamard wie zuvor, und qubit 1 in den Zustand 1 / 2 0 - 1
mit einem NOT-gate gefolgt von einem Hadamard.
Der vollständige Zustand an diesem Punkt hier ist also, wobei dies der Zustand von qubit 0 und
dies der Zustand von qubit 1 ist. qubit 1 auf diese Weise vorzubereiten, anstatt es einfach
im Zustand null zu belassen, ermöglicht es dem Algorithmus, Quanten-Parallelismus in Kombination mit Interferenz zu nutzen, um etwas über
die Black-Box-Funktion zu erfahren. Schauen wir uns an, was passiert, wenn die qubits in UF, das Black-Box-gate, eingespeist werden – es können ein paar Dinge
geschehen. Wenn die Funktion konstant ist, führt die Black Box eine bestimmte Operation auf qubit 1 allein durch, unabhängig
vom Zustand von null. Da UF in diesem Fall qubit 0 nicht berührt oder
sich um seinen Zustand kümmert, macht das zweite Hadamard hier einfach rückgängig, was
das erste Hadamard getan hat. Und wir werden messen, dass der qubit im Zustand null ist. Schauen wir uns die balancierte Funktion f_sub_2 als Beispiel an, um zu sehen,
was UF in diesem Fall mit dem Zustand macht. Wenn x null ist, ist f von x null, und wenn x
1 ist, ist f von x 1. Erinnerst du dich, was ich dir über das UF-gate gesagt habe? Es nimmt qubit 0
als unseren Eingabe-x-Zustand und gibt f von x auf qubit 1 aus. Vorausgesetzt, dass qubit 1
im Nullzustand gestartet ist. Für diese Funktion hängt also das, was UF mit qubit 1 macht, von
qubit 0 ab. Wenn 0 null ist, bleibt qubit 1 im Nullzustand, um f
von x = 0 zu erhalten. Wenn qubit 0 gleich 1 ist, wendet die Black Box ein NOT-gate auf qubit 1 an und versetzt es
in den Zustand eins. Wir erhalten also f von 1 gleich 1. Das ist genau das, was ein kontrolliertes NOT oder ein C-NOT-gate macht. Ein
C-NOT-gate nimmt zwei qubits, ein Steuer-qubit und ein Ziel-qubit, und kippt den
Zustand des Ziel-qubit, wenn das Steuer-qubit im Zustand eins ist. Aber es tut nichts mit dem Ziel, wenn das Steuer-
qubit im Zustand null ist. Also ist UF für F2 einfach ein C-NOT auf Q0 und Q1. Das C-
NOT-gate wirkt nicht auf den ersten Term, da das Steuer-qubit im Zustand null ist. Aber beim zweiten Term wird diese
0 zu 1 und diese 1 zu 0 gekippt. Und wenn wir ein Minuszeichen ausklammern, sehen wir, dass der Zustand von qubit 1
unverändert bleibt. Aber dieser Term hat ein Minuszeichen aufgenommen. Der Zustand von qubit 0 ist also
tatsächlich derjenige, der sich verändert hat. Er wechselte von 0 + 1 zu 0 minus
1. Wenn wir das abschließende Hadamard auf qubit 0 anwenden, transformiert es sich in den Zustand 1. Wenn die Funktion in der Black Box also
f_sub_2 ist, messen wir eine 1 anstelle einer 0. Es stellt sich heraus, dass das UF-gate für die andere balancierte Funktion f3
denselben C-knot gate, gefolgt von einem knot auf qubit 1. Dieses letzte not gate beeinflusst qubit null nicht. Wenn die Funktion
ausgewogen ist, messen wir qubit 0 am Ende des circuit im Zustand eins. Falls du nicht allem gefolgt bist,
ist das in Ordnung. Ich empfehle dir, es selbst durchzugehen, um zu sehen, wie es funktioniert. Der wesentliche Punkt hier ist, was
passierte, als wir den C-knot für die zwei ausgewogenen Funktionen anwendeten. Qubit 0 wurde nur als Steuer-qubit verwendet, um den
Zustand von qubit 1 zu ändern. Intuitiv könnte man denken, dass qubit 0 unverändert bleibt. Und doch verändern unsere
Operationen auf qubit eins tatsächlich den Zustand von qubit null, indem sie die relative Phase zwischen den zwei Teilen seiner
Überlagerung verändern. Dieses Phänomen ist als Phase-Kickback-Mechanismus bekannt und er ist
ausgesprochen kontraintuitiv, wie viele Quantenphänomene. In gewisser Weise kann man den Phase-Kickback-Mechanismus
mit dem Rudern eines Bootes vergleichen. Das Zurückschieben des Wassers treibt dich tatsächlich vorwärts. Genau wie die Operationen auf
qubit 1 tatsächlich qubit null verändern. Jetzt können wir den Algorithmus von Deutsch auf
Qiskit ausführen. Hier können wir auswählen, welche Funktion in die Black Box gesteckt wird – wir haben uns für F3 entschieden. Hier ist das
circuit-Diagramm des Algorithmus, und wir können ihn wie zuvor mit dem Sampler-Primitive ausführen. Wir setzen die Anzahl der
Samples auf eins und schauen, was wir messen. In diesem Fall haben wir eins gemessen.
Also wissen wir, dass die Funktion ausgewogen war, was genau das ist, was wir erwartet haben, da die Black Box die Funktion f3 enthielt. Mit nur einer einzigen
Anfrage konnten wir zwischen diesen zwei Klassen von Funktionen unterscheiden.
Ein klassischer Algorithmus hätte zwei Anfragen gebraucht, um das zu bestimmen. Dies zeigt einen bescheidenen Vorteil von Quanten-
computing gegenüber klassischem Computing allein, aber es ist nicht besonders beeindruckend. Nur eins gegen zwei. Aber der Algorithmus von Deutsch
ist dennoch äußerst wichtig für die Geschichte des Quantencomputings, weil er den Funken lieferte, der andere dazu brachte,
über größere, ausgefeiltere Quantenalgorithmen nachzudenken.
Dazu gehört eine Mehr-qubit-Erweiterung von Deutschs Algorithmus, die einen weitaus beeindruckenderen Quantenvorteil demonstriert.
Dies wird als Deutsch-Josa-Algorithmus bezeichnet. Er löst ein ähnliches Problem, aber in diesem Fall nimmt die Black-Box-Funktion,
über die wir etwas lernen möchten, n Bits als Eingabe und gibt ein einzelnes Bit aus. Wie
zuvor wird versprochen, dass die Funktion entweder konstant ist, das heißt das Ausgabe-Bit ist immer eins oder immer null,
unabhängig vom Eingabe-Bit-String, oder ausgewogen, das heißt die Ausgabe ist null für
die Hälfte der Eingabe-Bit-Strings und eins für die andere Hälfte. Es gibt natürlich auch andere
Funktionen, die n Bits auf ein einzelnes Bit abbilden und weder konstant noch ausgewogen sind. Aber bei diesem Problem wird
versprochen, dass keine dieser Funktionen in der Black Box steckt. Die Funktion in der Box ist garantiert entweder konstant
oder ausgewogen. Der Deutsch-Josa-circuit sieht ähnlich aus wie der Algorithmus von Deutsch, aber mit mehr qubits. Hier haben wir eine
Implementierung des Deutsch-Josa-Algorithmus, um eine Drei-Bit-Funktion zu untersuchen. Diesmal haben wir drei qubits
für den Eingabezustand statt nur einem. Und dann haben wir dieses letzte qubit für den Ausgabezustand. Wie zuvor
bereiten wir alle Eingabe-qubits im Zustand 0 + eins und das Ausgabe-qubit
im Zustand 0 minus eins vor. Dann, obwohl die Mathematik etwas komplizierter zu verfolgen ist, bleibt das Prinzip
dasselbe. Wenn die Funktion konstant ist, hängt sie überhaupt nicht von den oberen drei qubits ab. Daher werden ihre Zustände
nach den zweiten Hadamards wieder auf null transformiert, und unsere Messung ergibt einen Drei-Bit-String aus lauter
Nullen. Aber wenn die Funktion ausgewogen ist, wird beim Messen der qubits nach den Hadamards der Phase-Kickback-
Mechanismus dafür sorgen, dass eines oder mehrere dieser Bits eins ist. Das ist diesmal vielleicht nicht so leicht zu sehen, aber wenn du
jeden Schritt selbst durcharbeitest, wirst du bald sehen, dass dies der Fall sein muss. Eine Möglichkeit, dies zu überprüfen, besteht darin, die
Wahrscheinlichkeit zu berechnen, mit einer ausgewogenen Funktion lauter Nullen zu messen. Du solltest eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von null erhalten. Lass uns den
Deutsch-Josa-Algorithmus auf einem Quantencomputer mit Qiskit ausführen. Der schwierigste Schritt ist wahrscheinlich das Erstellen der Deutsch-Josa-
Funktion. Das wird unsere Black Box sein, die wir hier abfragen. Dieser Code erzeugt eine zufällige Deutsch-Josa-Funktion, die
garantiert entweder ausgewogen oder konstant ist. Dann erstellen wir unseren Deutsch-Josa-circuit und fügen unsere Black Box
Funktion hier ein. Wieder führen wir den circuit mit Sampler aus, und nachdem wir gemessen haben, schauen wir uns
die gemessenen Bits an, um festzustellen, ob die Funktion ausgewogen oder konstant war.
Wenn sie alle null sind, ist sie konstant. Aber wenn mindestens ein Eins-Bit im String vorkommt, dann ist sie ausgewogen. In diesem
Fall erhalten wir einen Bit-String aus 1 eins eins.
Also wissen wir, dass die Funktion ausgewogen war. Ich hoffe, ich habe dir einen ersten Einblick gegeben, wie Quantenalgorithmen
interessante und oft subtile Quantenphänomene nutzen können, um ihren Vorteil gegenüber klassischen
Algorithmen zu erlangen. Du hast wahrscheinlich auch gemerkt, wie knifflig das Entwerfen von Quantenalgorithmen sein kann. Sogar der allererste
erforderte viel Kreativität, um nur einen bescheidenen Sieg über klassische Methoden zu erzielen. Und seit diesem ersten Algorithmus
haben Physiker und Informatiker weiterhin unglaublich einfallsreiche Wege gefunden, die Quantenmechanik
zu ihrem Vorteil einzusetzen, einschließlich weiterer Erweiterungen und Anwendungen des Deutsch-Josa-Algorithmus. Wenn du über
einige davon mehr erfahren und den Deutsch- sowie den Deutsch-Josa-Algorithmus selbst ausprobieren möchtest, geh zu
dem in der Beschreibung verlinkten Modul, um loszulegen. Danke fürs Zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal.